THIS IS THE FIVE.
AN UNPRECEDENTED EVENT AT THE
WHITE HOUSE THIS MORNING,
PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKING HIS WAY
THROUGH A MOB OF REPORTERS FOR
AN IMPROMPTU INTERVIEW ON
"FOX & FRIENDS."
THE PRESIDENT THEN ON LOADING ON
TOP FBI BRASS ON THE
INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT.
>> AT THE TOP PEOPLE WERE
HORRIBLE.
WE LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED TO COME
UP THEY WERE PLOTTING AGAINST MY
ELECTION.
THE IG REPORT WITH A HORROR
SHOW.
IF YOU LET THE FBI TAKE A REPORT
OF THE REAL FBI, NOT THE SCUM ON
TOP.
I THINK THE REPORT YESTERDAY MAY
BE MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN
ANYTHING, IT EXONERATES ME.
>> Kimberly: THE PRESIDENT
ALSO TOOK AIM AT AIM AT SPACE
SPECIAL AGENT PETER STRZOK.
>> President Trump: I AM
AMAZED THAT PETER STRZOK IS
STILL AT THE FBI AND SO IS
EVERYONE ELSE THAT      DUMB LIE
EVERYONE ELSE THAT      DUMB LIT
EVERYONE ELSE THAT      DUMB LIA
BEFORE.
AND I'M NOT EVEN TALKING ABOUT
THE REPORT, I'M TALKING ABOUT
LONG BEFORE THE REPORT.
>> Kimberly: PRESIDENT TRUMP
HAMMERING FIRED FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY.
>> President Trump: IF THEY
SEEM LIKE VERY CRIMINAL ACTS TO
ME.
WHAT HE DID WAS CRIMINAL, WHAT
HE DID WAS A TERRIBLE THING TO
THE PEOPLE.
WHAT HE DID WAS SO BAD IN TERMS
OF OUR CONSTITUTION AND THE
WELL-BEING OF OUR COUNTRY WHAT
HE DID WAS HORRIBLE.
SHOULD HE BE LOCKED UP?
WE WILL LET THEM MAKE THE
DETERMINATION.
>> Kimberly: STRONG WORDS
COMING FROM THE PRESIDENT THIS
MORNING IN AN IMPROMPTU
CONFERENCE THERE, SPEAKING WITH
STEVE DOOCY.
AND THE OTHER DEUCE HE WAS THERE
AS WELL.
IT WAS A DOOZY SANDWICH.
>> DOUG DUCEY DEUCE.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS INTERESTING
AND REVIEW FROM THE PRESIDENT,
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY WHAT HE
SAID ABOUT STRZOK, THAT GUY
SHOULD NOT BE THERE.
AND A STRZOK OF IT AND HIS
COMPATRIOTS, IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY
ARE MEMBERS OF THE RESISTANCE
THE WAY THEY TALK ABOUT TRUMP
SUPPORTERS.
THEY SAID THAT THEY ARE ALL
MIDDLE-CLASS, UNEDUCATED, LAZY
POS'S, AND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT
STANDS FOR.
AND HE SAYS WE WILL STOP THEM TO
LISA PAGE.
THERE IS NOT A SINGLE PRO TRUMP
TEXT.
THERE'S NOT ANY ANTI-HILLARY
TEXTS, IT'S ALL AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
SO WHEN THE IG REPORT COMES OUT
AND SAID THERE'S NO POLITICAL
BIAS, THERE IS EXTREME POLITICAL
BIAS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW THEY COULD SAY
THAT WITH A STRAIGHT FACE.
IT WAS ANTI-TRUMP FROM THE JUMP,
AND YOU UNDERSTAND WHEN YOU LOOK
AT JAMES COMEY, HE KNEW LORETTA
LYNCH AND HER BOSS,
BARACK OBAMA, DIDN'T WANT
HILLARY CLINTON CHARGED.
HE'S NOT GOING TO STOP THE FIRST
FEMALE PRESIDENT FROM TAKING
OFFICE.
THAT'S WHY A LOT OF THE FBI
AGENTS WERE INTIMIDATED AND THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO TOUGH,
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT WHEN SHE
GETS INTO THE OVAL, SHE WAS
GOING TO CRACK DOWN ON THEM.
THEY KNEW SHE WAS GOING TO BE
PRESIDENT AND THAT'S WHY THE FIX
WAS IN.
THEN ONCE TRUMP OUT THE
NOMINATION THEY TURNED THE
SCREWS TO HIM AND TREATED HIM
AND HIS PEOPLE VERY UNFAIRLY.
THE WAY COMEY BEHAVED DURING
THIS WHOLE TIME, HE USED PRIVATE
EMAIL.
HE EXONERATED HILLARY.
HE CHANGED THE LANGUAGE OF THE
LAW TO MAKE IT ABOUT INTENT, AND
INTENT HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH
IT.
THIS REPORT JUSTIFIES TRUMP'S
FIRING OF JAMES COMEY, AND
PRETTY MUCH EXONERATES A
PRESIDENT WITH REGARD TO WHAT HE
HAS BEEN SAYING ABOUT THE
HILLARY CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
IT WAS CROOKED AND REMAINS EVEN
MORE CROOKED.
>> Kimberly: BUT JESSE, WHAT
JAMES COMEY IS CRITICIZED FOR IN
THE AG REPORT, THE THINGS HE
DID, GOING OUT IN JULY AND
HAVING THAT PRESS CONFERENCE,
GOING IN OCTOBER AND TALKING
ABOUT REOPENING THE
INVESTIGATION, THOSE THINGS ALL
HELPED DONALD TRUMP.
IT DIDN'T HURT HILLARY.
>> HE COULD HAVE CHARGED HER AND
TAKEN HER TOTALLY OUT OF PLAY.
>> LET ME COUNTER BACK THOUGH.
THERE ARE A LOT OF FBI OFFICERS,
MOST OF THE LAW ENFORCEMENT
TENDS TO LEAN CONSERVATIVE.
>> HAVE YOU HEARD THEM TALK?
THEY DON'T SOUND LIKE
CONSERVATIVES.
>> LET ME FINISH.
IF THIS DEEP STATE
LAW ENFORCEMENT FBI GROUP WANTED
TO TAKE DOWN DONALD TRUMP, WHY
DIDN'T THEY LIKE THE FACT THAT
HIS CAMPAIGN WAS UNDER
INVESTIGATION?
>> THEY DIDN'T THINK HE WAS
GOING TO WIN.
>> IF THEIR GOAL WAS TO TAKE HIM
DOWN, WHICH I DON'T THINK IT WAS
THEN WHY WOULD THEY DO THAT?
WHY DIDN'T THEY LEAK -- >> THEY
DID LEAK TO THE TIMES IN
OCTOBER.
>> THEY WERE QUITE CERTAIN OF
THAT AS A DETERMINATIVE OUTCOME
WHICH WAS THAT HILLARY CLINTON
WAS GOING TO BECOME THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
THEN THEY SHIFTED TACTICS AND
MOVED TOWARDS UNDERMINING THE
CANDIDACY OF DONALD TRUMP AND
ULTIMATELY THE PRESIDENT.
SO THIS IS JUST PART OF WHAT IS
GOING TO BE COMING FORWARD IN
TERMS OF THE IG REPORT.
YOU HAVE THOSE REVELATIONS BUT
KEEP IN MIND, THOSE DOCUMENTS,
THE VOLUMINOUS AMOUNT AND PAGES
THAT WE SAW, THOSE ARE STILL
REDACTED BY ROD ROSENSTEIN, WHO
IS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
NEFARIOUS CIRCLE OF MALFEASANCE.
>> THERE STILL A LOT OF
QUESTIONS TO BE ASKED HERE.
YOU'RE GOING BACK AND FORTH ON
WHO HAD HELPED AND WHO WOULD
HURT, BUT ISN'T THE PROBLEM THAT
THERE WAS POLITICS TO BEGIN
WITH?
THE SAD THING TO ME IS, YOU HAVE
OVER 100,000 PEOPLE THAT WORK
WITHIN DOJ AND MANY OF THEM ARE
GREAT PEOPLE.
THE PRESIDENT POINTED THAT OUT
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT POINT TO
MAKE BECAUSE YOU FEEL FOR THEM
IN THIS MOMENT.
THEY ARE THE ONES DOING THEIR
JOB THAT ARE POLITICAL.
THERE WILL BE A HEARING ON
MONDAY, AND TUESDAY I BELIEVE IN
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE.
THE BIG QUESTION, KIMBERLY, DOES
ACTION NEED TO BE TAKEN OUT
LUNGED NOT JUST PETER STRZOK AND
LISA PAGE ABOUT OTHER AGENTS?
THEY SAID TERRIBLE THINGS ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND OF THE
PEOPLE THAT SUPPORT
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
SO WHERE DOES THIS END?
DO THEY SAY, THAT'S PRETTY BAD,
LET'S MOVE ON?
OR DO THEY LEARN FROM IT?
>> THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SAYING, CONTINUE THE
INVESTIGATION AND FIND OUT IT
WHAT IF ANY ACTION NEEDS TO BE
DETERMINED.
WHAT NEEDS TO HAPPEN TO JAMES
COMEY.
>> CAN WE FIRST ADDRESS WHAT
HAPPENED THIS MORNING WHICH WAS
IN GENERAL?
THIS IS THE TRANSCRIPT I HAD TO
COME UP IT'S 50 PAGES.
THE MEDIA SHOULD STOP AND THANK
DONALD TRUMP FOR BEING THE MOST
TRANSPARENT PRESIDENT.
HE TALKS FOR 51 MINUTES ABOUT
EVERYTHING.
FORGET THE IG, HE'S THE OG.
>> HE WENT LIKE 300 DAYS ALMOST.
THERE IS NO SUCH THING IN
DONALD TRUMP'S WORLD AS, NO
COMMENT.
IF YOU LET HIM GO, AT SOME POINT
HE WILL SAY YOUR NAME.
WE SAW THAT WITH STUART VARNEY.
IF HE KEEPS TALKING, HE WILL
SAY, KITTENS ARE JUST LIKE
UNICORNS, BUT SMALLER.
SO THAT'S MY TAKE ON THE ACTUAL
PRESSER, WHICH I THOUGHT WAS
FANTASTICALLY ENTERTAINING AND
WILL GIVE US THREE SEGMENTS
TODAY ON FRIDAY.
BUT LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BIG
DEAL.
HERE, THE TEXT BETWEEN PETER
STRZOK AND LISA PAGE.
90% OF MY TEXTS ARE CARELESS AND
HYPERBOLE.
AT THE TIME I'M KIND OF BUZZ
WHEN I TEXT PEOPLE.
>> THEY ARE FRIGHTENING.
[LAUGHS]
>> WHEN YOU READ A FELLOW
INVESTIGATOR SAYING COME UP THEY
WILL STOP TRUMP, IF THAT'S NOT
POLITICAL BIAS, WHAT CONSTITUTES
POLITICAL BIAS?
THERE'S ALMOST NO STEP BEYOND
WHAT HE SAYING, SHORT OF
ADVOCATING VIOLENCE FOR AN
OVERTHROW, OR SOMETHING.
I MEAN IT'S LIKE, WHAT WOULD YOU
HAVE TO SAY THAT IS BEYOND THAT?
THAT'S THE LIMIT.
SO I THINK -- I THINK YOU COULD
INTERPRET IT AND SAY IT'S LIKE,
TWO LEVERS TRYING TO IMPRESS
EACH OTHER, TO HEROES IN THEIR
OWN LOVE STORY, BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THAT, MAN, IT ISN'T
PRETTY.
>> AND LET'S REMEMBER WHO HE
WAS, HE WAS THE LEAD
INVESTIGATOR FOR THE CLINTON
EMAIL PROBE.
HE INTERVIEWED ALL OF HILLARY'S
PEOPLE AND HE TRAVELED TO
ENGLAND TO TALK TO THE QUOTE
UNQUOTE SPY.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT OFFICIALLY
OPENED UP THE
COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION INTO DONALD TRUMP
AND HE WAS THE ONE THAT
INTERVIEWED MIKE FLYNN.
HE WAS HANDPICKED TO GO ON TO
MUELLER'S TEAM.
THE KEY PLAYER IN BOTH
INVESTIGATIONS AND HE'S OUT
THERE TALKING ABOUT, WE NEED TO
STOP HIM FROM BECOMING PRESIDENT
AND IT NOW THAT HE IS PRESIDENT
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT
IT.
>> AND THAT'S WHY TREY GOWDY
SAID THIS MOLAR PROBE IS
TAINTED.
NO MATTER WHAT COMES OUT OF IT,
SHOULD WE TAKE IT SERIOUSLY?
BECAUSE AS HE SAID, PETER STRZOK
WAS ONE OF THE TOP PEOPLE
ORIGINALLY ON THAT INVESTIGATION
AND YOU HEARD RUDY GIULIANI THIS
MORNING, HE SAID WE ARE NOT
GOING TO COOPERATE ANYMORE.
WHO KNOWS HOW THIS ENDS, IT MAY
END UP GOING ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT BUT YOU CAN'T
ARGUE THAT THE EARLY DAYS OF
THIS INVESTIGATION CERTAINLY
WERE TAINTED.
>> I THINK THE TEXT MESSAGES ARE
AWFUL AND THEY GIVE THE
APPEARANCE OF BIAS.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL ALSO SAID
THEY DIDN'T FIND ANY EVIDENCE
THAT IMPACTED THE INVESTIGATION.
>> THE CLINTON INVESTIGATION.
>> THEY ALSO SAID THAT PETER
STRZOK AT TIMES ADVOCATED FOR
TOUGHER ACTION AGAINST THE
CLINTON PEOPLE INCLUDING THE USE
OF SUBPOENAS THAN OTHER PEOPLE
ON THE TEAM AND THAT HE WAS NOT
THE SOLE DECISION-MAKER ON
ANYTHING RELATED TO THE
INVESTIGATION.
SO I AGREE, THESE TEXTS GIVE A
VERY BAD APPEARANCE OF POLITICAL
BIAS AND IT WAS STUPID AND THEY
SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE IT, BUT WE
HAVE TO ALSO FOLLOW WHAT THE IG
SAID.
WE HAVE TO FOLLOW THE IG WHERE
THEY SAY THERE IS NO EVIDENCE
THAT IMPACTED INVESTIGATIVE
DECISIONS AND IN FACT, STRZOK
ARGUED FOR TOUGHER TREATMENT.
>> WHEN HE WROTE THE EXONERATION
LETTER, RECKLESS OR NOT, HE WAS
THE ONE THAT DOWNGRADED AND
CARELESS.
THE OTHER THING HE DID WHEN THEY
GOT THEIR HANDS ON THE
ANTHONY WEINER EMAILS, HE WAS
THE ONE THAT SAT ON THEM FOR A
MONTH AND THEY DIDN'T FUNNEL
THEIR WAY UP TO MUELLER UNTIL
RIGHT BEFORE THE ELECTION.
>> BUT THAT HURT HELLO RAY.
>> IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO IT
HELPS OR HURTS, THOUGH.
IF YOU ARE CHOOSING POLITICAL
BIAS IN FAVOR OF HILLARY -- >>
IT'S IN WRITING, WE DON'T NEED
TO SPECULATE.
IT'S THERE FROM BEGINNING TO END
THAT THEY HAD A SPECIFIC
INTENDED PURPOSE OF WHAT THEY
WANTED THE OUTCOME TO BE WHICH
DOES TAINT THE INVESTIGATION
MUELLER IS DOING BECAUSE THE KEY